by the Southern Poverty Law Center which
is a completely ersatz phony left-wing
lobby group posing as a human rights
organization totally dishonest and then
what happened next well a reporter from
ProPublica which is a soros funded
publication contacted me pointed out
that jihad watch has a donation link via
PayPal as well as my books for sale at
amazon.com and Newsmax news links and
said what would you do if all this was
cut off because you're a hate group as
according to the Southern Poverty Law
Center and I tried to actually reason
with this reporter Lauren Kirchner and
tell her the implications of what she
was suggesting and saying that if you
are allowing that people with unpopular
political opinions be cut off from these
platforms you better hope that doesn't
turn on you and your positions don't
become unpopular sometime in the future
but she published her article it led off
with me denounced me noted the Southern
Poverty Law Center's absolutely spurious
claim that on some sort of hate group
leader and within hours I was notified
by PayPal that I can no longer use their
platform what was so remarkable about
the ProPublica piece the Lauren curtain
piece that you're referring to which I
just read is that at no point does it
describe and I need to tell the views
that are supposedly hateful that you
hold it didn't it just described you as
a member or the leader of a hate group
but it never told viewers or readers
what that means it was by definition
propaganda it was garbage did did you
know this oh yeah sure I wrote about it
at jihad watch and pointed out that
Lauren Kirchner had not made any effort
to verify whether the Southern Poverty
Law Center was right or not about
whether on the hate group the the they
just the left seems to consider the
Southern Poverty Law Center infallible
in matters of who's a hate group and who
isn't so nobody else wait a minute who's
watching The Watchmen yeah what are the
biases of this supposed neutral arbiter
so I actually went to the Southern
Poverty Law Center website it hurt me to
do that but for the purposes of this
segment I I made myself and went to the
entry on you and because I wanted to
know I mean if you're saying things that
I'm appalled by I don't want to have you
on or I want to call you on them anyway
on the air I
find anything in your write-up that was
even particularly controversial or
out-of-bounds do you know what exactly
they're holding up as an example of your
hatefulness well I think that what we
have here is the left very common
tendency to take statements that are
absolutely true that they don't like and
portray them as hateful one of the main
things that I say in my work is that the
jihadis are working from real traditions
within Islam they're not all Muslims by
any means and all that not all Muslims
are terrorists or believe in what the
jihadis believe in but the jihadis can
and do point to the texts and teachings
of Islam to justify violence and make
recruits among peaceful Muslims now this
is an obvious fact that I've documented
thousands of times on jihad watch but as
far as the left goes if you even suggest
that Islam is not a religion of peace or
that might not be a religion of peace in
every conceivable way then you're a hate
monger and a bigot and an Islamophobe
ayaan Hirsi Ali was also listed on the
SPLC website as a hater this is someone
who grew up in Somalia and was the
victim of female genital mutilation but
for criticizing that religion she's a
hater really quickly can you think of
any examples of people who've criticized
I don't know Christianity who are on the
Southern Poverty Law Center's website as
leaders you know not only do they not
have any but of course leftists in
general celebrate that sort of thing
Richard Dawkins the famous state famous
atheist writer a critic of Christianity
critic of Islam critic of all religions
and religion itself he was recently
disinvited from a speech in California
because the organizers found out he
criticized Islam they thought it was
great when he criticized Christianity
but criticizing Islam has been set up as
the third rail the thing you must not
touch in the American public square why
do the elites in our society hate
themselves so much and hate our society
so much do you think I think that it it
comes from the idea of a certain kind of
guilt over success and that the West has
been very successful and its culture is
celebrated all over the world and the
they think they feel guilty about that
and think that we have to apologize and
bring in all these other cultures to
make up for this it's really sick I wish
Ford we're still around for a diagnosis
thank thanks so much for joining us and
congratulations on being back among the
living thank you